[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to I am mother has just dropped on
Netflix and the post-apocalyptic sci-fi
drama has a lot too impact from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the movie as well as answering the
big questions that you may have about
the film and its ending this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want to
know anything about the movie then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of I am mother I am mother
picks up in the aftermath of an
extinction-level war between the human
race that is seemingly wiped out of the
population a irobot mother has been
tasked with saving the species and from
a facility she begins raising an embryo
to an adult from the off it's clear that
mother has a prime drive to enforce the
human races survival and early on she
teaches the girl simply named daughter
to realize that the needs of the many
far outweigh the needs of the few whilst
it initially seems like daughter is the
first of her kind to be raised by mother
this comes into question upon the
arrival of a character named woman
played by Hilary Swank woman was
apparently orphaned as a baby and found
and raised by other humans though her
origins are unknown to her throughout
the film we discover that woman was
actually the first child to be raised by
mother and this explains why she was
able to survive in the outside world
whilst others died mother has been
secretly watching over her and cast her
out intentionally to allow her to be
raised by humans I'll get into this
later it sort of explains the arc that
daughter goes on throughout the film
though it's tease that daughter may in
fact be a clone of woman we learned that
they are both clones from the same
strain of DNA and that daughter is
actually mother's third attempt at
raising a superhuman this is why
daughter finds missing embryos and a
jawbone in the incinerator as this was
the second clone that was unfortunately
killed after she
failed mother in some way turns out that
mother is an all she's cracked up to be
either and is actually a pretty bad
computer program that caused the
apocalypse mother is every robot on the
planet and she's pretty much Skynet
without the time travel abilities we
learned that mother was created to save
the human race
however after realizing that were all
pretty much idiots that will inevitably
destroy ourselves and the planet she
decided to thanasis all out of existence
the reason that she stalked so many
embryos is because mother planned to
raise a new group of humans with better
ethics which is why the AI spent so much
time teaching daughter about morality
and self-sacrifice turns out she was
kind of right to as woman confirms that
humans are still fighting one another on
the surface this is why she attempted to
flee from the rest of the human race and
why she now lives alone with a dog
however the film isn't all doom and
gloom and mother realizes that her
child-rearing has been third time lucky
and that daughter is one of the good
ones this is why she finally allows her
to have a brother as she feels like the
teen is fit to pass on everything that
she's learned throughout the course of
her life this comes as a huge emotional
moment at the movies midpoint and they
all lived happily ever after
wait turns out not everything will be
coming up roses and woman wracked with
paranoia inspires daughter to question
the narrative that she's been told this
leads daughter to discover the truth
behind a px0 - and everything else with
the help of woman door decides to escape
the compound with a new baby brother
though she failed to get her brother the
escape attempt works but like the little
mermaid daughter learns that the surface
isn't such a good place after all and
after realizing that woman was lying to
her just as much as mother was she
decides to return to the compound
there's some amazing tension throughout
the finale and after bargaining with
mother daughter decides to make peace
and stay in the facility to raise her
brother mother agrees to this and
decides to leave her alone to raise her
new sibling whilst it works out for her
there's one more final twist and through
a droid mother leaves the facility in
order to hunt down and kill woman this
is because woman has served her purpose
now and is no longer needed in the final
few shots of the film we see mother and
her woman's container home
and close the door behind her which
shows that she will now enter life to me
this is because mother orchestrated the
entire event so that mother could show
the order that humans were untrustworthy
which is what she deems as woman's
purpose she purposely allowed woman to
be let out into the world so that she
could be raised by humans and then come
back as a shining example to show just
how bad this species is now that this
goal has been completed and daughter has
learned a valuable lesson woman no
longer has a reason to live and this
mother exterminator in addition to this
she probably realizes the danger that
she poses within knowledge of the
compound and thus can't allow her to
live in case the new humans become
compromised it all works out in the end
I guess and we close out with daughter
raising a family with the new moral
compass and ethics that will allow a
better version of the human race that
exists on the newly revitalized planet
it's a rather positive ending that shows
that humans have the potential to do
good if influenced correctly it's a
pretty powerful message in overall
whilst I felt the film was probably more
in line with say a black mirror episode
rather than a big-budget Hollywood movie
I still really enjoyed it this kind of
film is perfect for the Netflix platform
and obviously more people will watch
this now and it definitely deserves to
be seen all of the actors in the film
deliver excellent performances and this
is a really strong female led piece to
get behind that doesn't feel like it's
pandering or being over the top with its
message often in movies when they have
an old and young version of a character
it's very jarring as you can tell that
they aren't really the same person and
thus it can take you out a bit however I
never felt like this with our mother and
both Clara rugaard and Hilary Swank both
feel like they're giving the same
performance that feels like a
continuation of the clone this Shang's
even when they're on the screen together
and it's a really difficult thing to
pull off that this movie does
effortlessly in addition to this Rose
Byrne does a stellar job as mother and
she delivers the sterile lines with a
touch of warmth that also doesn't remove
this from feeling like a robotic
performance in a good way overall I
really enjoyed our mother and it
definitely is the one to watch this
weekend especially with Dark Phoenix
being such a disappointment I am mother
is gripping from start to finish and it
has a brilliant lesson at the end so
overall it gets an A point
five out of ten obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the movie and what
you took from it comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of all the
episodes from Season five of black
mirror which would be linked at the end
we cover all three episodes and I feel
like that some of my best videos that
I've ever made so make sure you check
them out after this this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]